Real-world objects are
fairly complicated.
Often, their virtual
representations
are greatly simplified.
When we compare this table
model from Google Warehouse
to its real-world
counterpart, we immediately
notice that many
details are missing.
These details are
what make designing
fabricable objects very
difficult for casual users.
In this work, we
present a modeling tool
that leverages information
from a collection
of fabricable designs, in order
to enable casual users to model
and build real-world objects.
To allow structure-preserving
manipulations,
we automatically
convert the designs
in our collection
to hierarchical
parameterized templates.
Our template model takes into
account global relationships,
such as symmetries and
articulation consistencies.
It is also not restricted to
fixed topologies, allowing
irregular patterns
to be rescaled.
Notice how the number and
position of connectors
changes, as the template
parameters vary.
Our modeling tool is based
on template manipulation
and composition.
We allow users to
explore the space
of template variations
using different levels
of the template hierarchy.
During manipulation, active
elements of the hierarchy
are shown in full color,
while other elements
are semitransparent.
Once a part is
positioned, the user
invokes a method that brings
in connecting elements
to the design, by exploring
the template database.
Notice how for our
a wooden tabletop,
corner brackets are
automatically brought in
to connect the top to the legs.
While, for a glass stop, a whole
support structure for the glass
is automatically added.
We incorporate in our system a
stability analysis evaluation
that warns the user if the
design model is unstable.
We illustrate a full
modeling session.
For composition, we
first assist the users
by snapping drag components
onto the working model.
The user can continue to
reposition and rescale
the model, until
she is satisfied
with the snap configuration.
The output of our system
is a comprehensive bill
of materials that can be
directly used for fabrication.
Here are some
additional results.
One of the main advantages of
using a data-driven approach
is its generality.
Notice how the same method that
creates tables and cabinets
can also be used on go-karts.